hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live es sind vermutlich die letzten
Stunden unter die Entschuldigung es sind
so möglich die letzten Stunden in denen
es noch Hoffnung gibt Überlebende unter
den Trümmern zu finden rund 65 Stunden
sind seit dem Erdbeben in der Türkei und
in Syrien inzwischen vorbei und mehr als
11.000 tote doppelt so viele wie gestern
wurden heute gemeldet so viel Zerstörung
und durch die vielen vermissten und
verletzten können die Zahlen natürlich
noch weiter steigen in der Türkei
immerhin ist inzwischen eben auch Hilfe
aus dem Ausland eingetroffen Retter
Helfer Suchtrupps aber die Chancen dass
sie verschüttete noch leben bergen
können die sinken eben von Stunde zu
Stunde es ist selten dass noch mehr als
72 Stunden noch jemanden Leben gefunden
wird und in Syrien dort sind die Zahlen
vielleicht sogar noch unklarer dort sind
viel weniger Retter und außerdem kommt
von den Hilfslieferungen fast nichts an
der Fokus in unserer Sendung heute ist
deshalb scheit Pflegehilfe für Syrien
und ihr könnt Fragen dazu stellen im
Stream per Mail kommentieren denn
darüber wollen wir heute sprechen und
uns eine halbe Stunde rund diesem Thema
jetzt widmen wie kann Hilfe Ankommen in
Syrien in Nordsyrien wo die Menschen
eben schon seit Jahren an Kriegsfolgen
leiden und
unterschiedliche Mächte die Region
beherrschen wir schauen zunächst in
einen Bericht ganz am Anfang in dieser
Sendung von golini atai über die Lage
vor Ort
Karim eine Kleinstadt im Bezirk Nordwest
Syrien
Einwohner haben freiwillige
zusammengerufen um am Tag 3 nach dem
Beben die wahrscheinlich letzten
Überlebenden zu retten selbst hier im
Kriegsgebiet wo sie Leid und Schmerz
seit Jahren kennen sind sie überwältigt
vom Ausmaß der Zerstörung
wir bitten die Vereinten Nationen wir
bitten die arabischen Länder und
Bergungsgerät zu schicken wir haben
wirklich nur wenig Ausrüstung hier wie
Sie sehen können reicht es nicht aus
immer wenn ein Kind überlebt hat jubeln
sie und geht ein Raunen durch die Menge
[Musik]
zehn Kilometer weiter in Salin eine
Mutter versucht ihre Tochter zu trösten
nachdem der Vater vor ihren Augen tot
geworden wurde
oh Gott ich hoffe da drin gibt es noch
lebende es sind mehr als 150 Seelen in
diesem Gebäude gefangen sagt Abu
Mohammad die sieben Angehörige vermisst
34 Tote liegen im kleinen provisorischen
Krankenhaus der Ortschaft 400 Verletzte
mussten sie bislang hier behandeln sagen
sie
für einen am ganzen Leib zitternden Mann
der gerade geborgen wurde gibt es kein
Bett mehr
seine Brüder versuchen ihn zu beruhigen
am Tag 3 ist in der oppositionsentklave
in Nordwest Syrien noch immer keine
Hilfe angekommen
luckily today wir hörten heute
glücklicherweise dass die Straße zum
Grenzübergang geöffnet werden konnte so
dass wir ab morgen hoffentlich die
Grenzregion erreichen können und die
Menschen dort
Aleppo im vom Assad-Regime
kontrollierten Gebiet in den betroffenen
Städten hier haben nach
Regierungsangaben fast 300.000 Menschen
ihre Häuser verlassen müssen Damaskus
fragt nun auch die EU um Hilfe an
ob es Hoffnung auf mehr Hilfe für die
Region gibt darüber können wir jetzt
sprechen mit Christoph Ionen er
koordinierte internationale
Zusammenarbeit beim Deutschen Roten
Kreuz schönen guten Abend Herr Johnen
guten Abend Herr Johnen schafft es denn
wirklich überhaupt mehr Hilfe in diese
Region mit eben all diesen
Herausforderungen die wir jetzt schon
kurz gehört haben
ich glaube der Bericht hat sehr deutlich
gemacht dass die Hilfe in Syrien noch um
ein Vielfaches komplexer und
herausfordernder ist als es auch in der
Türkei ist
ich glaube dabei darf man natürlich
nicht vergessen und das haben die Bilder
die Sie soeben zeigten auch sehr
deutlich gemacht das ist natürlich vor
allem das ist aber auch in der Türkei so
die Menschen vor Ort diejenigen sind die
die erste Hilfe leisten die häufig auch
Überlebende retten und die sehr viel tun
das ist in allen Katastrophen so und es
ist sehr wertvolle Hilfe in Syrien kommt
die Komplexität hinzu dass eben durch
den im Land herrschenden seit mehr als
10 Jahren herrschenden Konflikt
internationale Hilfe erschwert wird und
insbesondere natürlich auch die Einfuhr
oder der ja die Verfügbarkeit von
schweren Bergens Gerät in den ersten
Tagen eigentlich nicht vorhanden war und
ist
und warum ist das so schwer Zugang zu
bekommen zu diesen Regionen im Norden
von Syrien
es ist zum einen natürlich dass die
Infrastruktur in der Türkei eine viel
bessere ist das Augenmerk hat sich auch
darauf gerichtet und dann gibt es in
Syrien eben zum einen es gibt ja zwei
betroffene Regionen kann man sagen
einmal der die Region die von der
syrischen Regierung kontrolliert wird
und dann eben die Region ganz im
Nordwesten des Landes die von der
bewaffneten Opposition kontrolliert wird
und in beide Regionen ist es eben kaum
möglich hineinzukommen da ist zum einen
die Sache in den Nordwesten da war der
Grenzübergang aus der Türkei der
geöffnet ist auch für humanitäre Hilfe
der war eben vorübergehen nicht
passierbar und alle andere Hilfe müsste
eben aus dem Binnenland Syriens kommen
und eben schweres Bergens Gerät doch
hineinzubringen ist eben auch nicht so
einfach die logistische Infrastruktur
besteht nicht und es hat ja jetzt die
syrische Regierung hat ja auch die EU um
Hilfe ersucht aber das ist natürlich
gerade für solche Material intensiven
schweren ret Interaktionen in den ersten
Tagen dann jetzt auch beinahe zu spät
sie haben es angesprochen also es gibt
den Teil von der syrischen Regierung
kontrolliert es gibt den Teil von den
Rebellen kontrolliert können Sie mit
denen überhaupt kooperieren ist mit der
syrischen Regierung überhaupt eine
Kooperation möglich
na selbstverständlich also für uns als
rotes Kreuz wir arbeiten immer über die
jeweiligen Rotkreuz oder rotalpen und
Gesellschaften in den Ländern das ist
jetzt in den beiden betroffenen Ländern
der türkische Rote Halbmond oder der
syrische Rote Halbmond aufgrund des
Konfliktes im Lande sind wir als
Deutsches Rotes Kreuz seit mehr als 10
Jahren auch mit eigenen Personal im Land
das heißt es ist Expertise da es sind
vor allem aber die freiwilligen
Helferinnen und Helfer des syrischen
arabischen roten halb Mondes vor Ort
aber was natürlich nicht in Syrien so
möglich ist wie es in der Türkei möglich
war oder auch einfach nicht passiert es
ist das eben dieses schwere Bergens
Gerät in den ersten Tagen ins Land
gekommen ist
Probleme eben etwas ins Land zu bekommen
das liegt auch daran weil bislang ist
nur ein einziger Grenzübergang von der
Türkei nach Syrien aktuell offen zwei
weitere so gab es jetzt eben aktuelle
Berichte sollen nach Angaben des
türkischen Außenministeriums geöffnet
werden die deutsche Außenministerin
Annalena baerbock die forderte die
Öffnung aller Grenzübergänge um eben
schnelle humanitäre Hilfe zu ermöglichen
das wäre also auch eine Forderung die
sie unterstützen würden
ich glaube es ist nach diesem Erdbeben
kann es eigentlich nur die die Forderung
sein und die Maxime sein und das ist
eine ganz klar humanitäre Forderung wie
auch immer der Zugang zu betroffenen
Menschen möglich ist diesen zu
ermöglichen und zwar so schnell wie es
irgendwie geht zu ermöglichen
ja wie schwer das ist eben die Hilfe
rein ins Land zu bekommen ganz kurz vor
der Sendung da haben wir auch mit
Christoph lindmeier von der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation darüber
gesprochen und er hat uns geantwortet
wir hören mal kurz zusammen rein
wir haben einen Flugzeug das im Moment
unterwegs ist von Dubai und zum
zentralen hab nach Damaskus und die
müssen sich natürlich dann den Weg in
den Nordwesten von Syrien Vorarbeiten
was nicht ganz ohne Problematik ist und
die zweiten Möglichkeiten ist natürlich
aus der Gegend die immer schon in
Nordwesten von Syrien mit militären
Gütern in den letzten Jahren zehn ja
schon fast versorgt hat und zwar aus der
gaziante gegen jetzt haben wir das
Problem dass natürlich in gaziante
selber eine oder in der ganzen
südöstlichen Türkei hier ein riesen
humanitäres Problem besteht und die
Straßen teilweise zerstört sind
Grenzübergänge teilweise zerstört
sondern ich habe vorher gerade die
Nachricht bekommen dass der Papa habe
aber Grenze übergangen ja doch scheinbar
der bisher der einzige war als zerstört
ist und das oder zumindest nicht ganz
einsatzbereit ist oder verfügbar ist und
jetzt haben wir doch zwei andere
Kontrollpunkte aufgemacht wurden und so
zumindestmöglichkeit ist reinzukommen
wir haben es auch schon von un-seite von
who Seite geschafft 16 Krankenhäuser
damit Material zu versorgen das ist
nicht ganz unwichtig aber es ist doch
noch ein Tropfen auf dem heißen Stein
Politik darf nicht das Ziel sein hier
oder darf nicht die Hauptrolle spielen
die Diplomatie ist allerdings wichtig um
hier alles auf den Weg zu bringen und
wenn die internationale Gemeinschaft
hier zusammenarbeitet und alle
angrenzenden Staaten hier guten Willen
sind dann müsste das auch vorwärts gehen
aber das letzte Wort ist hier glaube ich
leider auch noch nicht gesprochen
zerstörte Grenzübergänge zum einen das
haben wir gehört aber es sollen andere
Grenzübergänge eben von der syrischen
Regierung kontrolliert werden und dann
auch Hilfsgüter die ja
Hilfsorganisationen eben dringend
brauchen die dann über die Hauptstadt
Damaskus kommen die werden also von der
Assad Regierung mehr oder weniger
abgefangen und verteilt sagen Berichte
wie begegnen sie dieser Problematik im
Land dass sie überhaupt ein Hilfsgüter
kommen die sie natürlich auch zum
Einsatz dann bringen können ja
unterstützen in Syrien ja wie gesagt
seit mehr als 10 Jahren und wir
verteilen die Hilfen natürlich nicht
über die Regierung sondern über unsere
Schwester Gesellschaft in syrischen
Roten Halbmond das heißt das ist auch
direkt Hilfe von uns gehen an den
syrischen Roten Halbmond und und werden
dann auch eben über die logistische
Struktur des syrischen Roten Halbmondes
verteilt der Kollege von der WHO sprach
an im Augenblick es gibt bereits
Hilfsflüge nach Damaskus
auch über die rot-kreuz-rottalpen und
Bewegung aber auch da stellt sich die
Herausforderung der Flughafen Damaskus
ist natürlich nicht für eine solche
hilfsoperation ausgelegt es gibt auch da
bereits erste Engpässe und dann müssen
die Hilfsgüter in den Norden
transportiert werden da stehen dem
stehen auch zunächst mal ganz praktische
Hindernisse noch im Weg es hat halt
teilweise auch geschneit also auch die
Straßen hoch nach Aleppo die sind nicht
ohne weiteres passierbar es hat auch
durch das Erdbeben gibt es noch mal
Verzögerungen also es ist wirklich eine
Kombination aus sehr vielen Dingen die
da zusammen kommt und leider die Hilfe
enorm erschwert das beantwortet
hoffentlich auch die Frage die ich aus
der Community gerade bei Youtube gesehen
habe über die Versorgung in der Luft es
gibt noch weitere Kommentare und Fragen
zum einen lese ich hier von Anita Merkel
die bei Facebook schreibt öffnet endlich
die Grenzen damit Hilfsgüter und
Hilfskräfte dorthin kommen können
langsam wird das Zeitfenster sehr eng um
Leben zu retten und ich habe auch noch
weitere Fragen und Kommentare hier
gesehen
so Tanja schreibt bei Youtube die
Flughäfen in Aleppo wurden doch auch für
die Hilfe geöffnet oder was sagen sie
dazu
also nach meinem Wissen sind bisher die
großen Hilfslieferungen also auch mit
großen Flugzeugen nach Damaskus gegangen
das größere Hilfslieferungen also aus
großen Frachtmaschinen nach Aleppo
gegangen sind ist mir nicht bekannt das
heißt aber nicht dass es nicht doch
passiert ist
ansonsten gibt es natürlich auch noch
weitere Probleme denn seit der seit die
Protestbewegung 2011 mit Gewalt
niedergeschlagen wurde wurden auch
Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen das syrische
Regime verhängt das gab berichtet dass
das auch Probleme bereiten könnte aber
Hilfsgüter sind davon ausgenommen oder
ja
diese Sanktionsregime die es ja häufig
gibt das sind politische Instrumente und
alle dieser Sanktionsregime nicht nur in
Syrien sehen eigentlich immer bestimmte
Ausnahmegenehmigung für humanitäre Hilfe
vor
nichtsdestotrotz entfalten aber auch
diese Sanktionen dennoch eine Wirkung
auf humanitäre Hilfe weil es zum
Beispiel jetzt im Falle Syrien sehr
viele Banken gibt und auch sehr viele
Lieferanten Firmen die Hilfsgüter zur
Verfügung stellen die sehr zurückhaltend
sind oder
Geldtransfers oder auch Lieferungen erst
gar nicht machen weil sie Angst haben
trotz der humanitären Ausnahme
Regelungen in den Sanktionen in Konflikt
mit den Sanktionen zu geraten und es
gibt ja nicht nur eine Sanktion es gibt
ja dann verschiedene sanktions Regime
die von verschiedenen Ländern von
verschiedenen Staatengruppen erlassen
werden das Preis Sanktionen und das ist
etwas worauf er seit Jahren Hinweisen
haben zwar diese humanitären
Ausnahmeregelung die Umsetzung ergibt
sich daraus aber nicht unbedingt dass es
dann auch leicht geht und das ist im
Falle von Syrien seit Jahren das ist
nicht erst seit heute definitiv eine
zusätzliche Herausforderung diese
Zurückhaltung eben von Firmen und auch
von Banken sozusagen geschäftet also zu
liefern nach Syrien und das macht es
sehr schwer zum Schluss noch die Frage
kommt denn insgesamt genug Hilfe von
westlicher Seite ihrer Meinung nach
also ich glaube für Syrien muss die
Hilfe deutlich verstärkt werden zum
einen wir müssen so dramatisch natürlich
die Bilder aus den ersten Stunden und
Tagen sind aber wir müssen natürlich
auch an die nächsten Wochen Monate
denken und da ist es natürlich
insbesondere in Syrien so und das gilt
für alle Teile Syriens dass die
Infrastruktur im Land sehr geschwächt
ist und bei Infrastruktur da meine ich
das fängt an bei Wasserversorgung das
bedeutet aber auch sozusagen eine
soziale Infrastruktur Gesundheitswesen
und auch das wurde schon angesprochen
viele viele Menschen die im syrischen
Gesundheitswesen gearbeitet haben haben
das Land verlassen
Krankenhäuser und
Gesundheitseinrichtungen sind durch
Kampfhandlungen zerstört oder beschädigt
worden das heißt es gibt sowieso eine
Gesellschaft die sehr stark getroffen
ist und jetzt dieses Erdbeben diese
Schäden und diese Traumata durch das
Erdbeben zusätzlich die machen eine
glaube ich noch viel mehr Hilfe
erforderlich als es möglicherweise in
der Türkei der Fall ist zumal die Türkei
natürlich auch ein Land ist das glaube
ich in sich wesentlich resilienter
wesentlich widerstandsfähiger ist eine
türkische Gesellschaft die
widerstandsfähiger ist gegen solche
Schocks als die syrische Gesellschaft
ist sagt Christoph Juden vom Deutschen
Roten Kreuz vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
und Einschätzung heute abend ich danke
Ihnen
und realistisch das ist ob Hilfe
wirklich auch in Syrien ankommt das
werden wir jetzt auch noch einmal ein
bisschen genauer uns anschauen denn es
ist ja wirklich eine Region wir haben es
jetzt auch schon angesprochen im Norden
von Syrien eine komplizierte Region mit
unterschiedlichen Akteuren wird von
unterschiedlichen Akteuren kontrolliert
wir wollen uns das jetzt noch mal
genauer anschauen und auch gleich noch
mal analysieren zunächst ein Beitrag von
Franziska von tiesenhausen
das Bürgerkriegsland Syrien wird
inzwischen wieder zu großen Teilen vom
Assad-Regime kontrolliert sitzt der
Regierung ist die Hauptstadt Damaskus im
Nordosten des Landes liegt das kurdische
Autonomiegebiet dort haben die Kurden in
den vergangenen zehn Jahren eine
Selbstverwaltung eingerichtet den
Nordwesten weite Teile der Provinz edlib
und Teile der Provinz Aleppo
kontrollieren seit 2017 islamistische
Rebellen mit Verbindung zu al-Qaida sie
wollen das Assad Regime stürzen und
einen sunnitischen islamischen Staat
erschaffen das Katastrophengebiet
erstreckt sich über Gebiete die von
Damaskus kontrolliert werden und
Territorien unter der Kontrolle von
Rebellen und Kurden besonders schlimm
ist die Lage in der Region it lieb dort
melden Helfer der sogenannten weißhelme
bislang 1400 Tote und die Zahl der Opfer
könnte noch deutlich steigen die Retter
gehen davon aus dass noch hunderte von
Familien unter Trümmern verschüttet sind
die Probleme in der Region die
analysieren wir jetzt gemeinsam mit
Bente Scheller sie ist die Leiterin des
Referats nahost- und Nordafrika der
Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung hallo Frau
Scheller guten Abend Frau Scheller Assad
beschuldigt den Westen wegen der
Wirtschaftssanktionen die verhängt
worden sind dass das auch quasi die
Hilfe beeinträchtigen würde was sagen
sie zu so einer Anschuldigung die da
auch getätigt wurde
es ist ja nichts Neues diesen Punkt
haben er aber auch Russland immer wieder
gebracht bei all dem Elend dass wir ja
auch in den vorangegangenen Jahren schon
gesehen haben 90% der syrischen
Bevölkerung leben unter der Armutsgrenze
da hieß es immer das sein diese Aktion
des Westens das trägt natürlich nicht
ich meine wenn man sich die EU Sanktion
anschaut dann ist völlig klar der ganz
große Teil sind personenbezogene
Sanktion das heißt wir werden
individuellen des Assad Regimes
sanktioniert dafür dass sie an
Menschenrechtsverbrechen beteiligt waren
das heißt Sie können nicht mehr in die
EU einreisen oder ihre Gelder sind
eingefroren also dieser Teil der
Sanktion der den überwiegenden Teil der
EU Sanktionen ausmacht betrifft die
humanitäre Hilfe nicht im geringsten ich
denke auch dass sie immer wieder gesehen
haben wie das Regime dann wenn die
Rückfrage kommt was ist das denn konkret
was ihr gebrauchen könntet was jetzt
unter den Sanktionen nicht ins Land
kommt benennt es uns und dann werden wir
dafür sorgen dass es doch dorthin kommt
darauf gab es ja nie eine Antwort die
zufriedenstellend gewesen wäre die
tatsächlich darin gemündet hätte dass
etwas geliefert werden konnte und
deswegen fällt es mir sehr schwer ernst
zu nehmen dass das geschrieben jetzt
plötzlich sein Herz für die Bürger in
den Syriens entdeckt und dementsprechend
mit der Aufhebung der Sanktionen
versucht für diese etwas Positives zu
erwirken ja das Auswärtige Amt in Berlin
das stellte auch klar das Hilfsgüter
eben nicht sanktioniert sind die UNO die
forderte die syrische Regierung auf
Helfern Zugang zu den von den Rebellen
kontrollierten Gebieten zu ermöglichen
wir haben es ja auch gerade im Beitrag
gesehen eben welche unterschiedlichen
Akteure da in der Region sind der
un-hilfskoordinator für Syrien der sagte
wir können es uns nicht leisten zu
warten und zu verhandeln bis wir
verhandeln ist es vorbei ist es erledigt
was sagen sie dazu jetzt gerade
natürlich auch dieser Wettlauf gegen die
Zeit wir realistisch ist das denn dass
man den gewinnt
ja eben auch schon gesagt es geht
wirklich hier um Stunden und im
Wesentlichen sind alle Bedingungen so
ungünstig dass wir schneller etwas käme
desto wichtiger ist wäre aber natürlich
heißt es nicht dass der Moment dann
verpasst ist und man die Hände in den
Schoß legen sollte ganz im Gegenteil ich
denke wir sollten jetzt wirklich alles
daran setzen das Hilfen dort hinkommen
und deswegen ist auch dieses die Frage
der Grenzübergänge ganz entscheidend
diese müssen geöffnet werden und da muss
humanitäre Hilfe auf jedem Wege
hineingebracht werden und geleistet
werden da können wir uns jetzt keine
politischen Ränke Spieler anschauen wie
wir sie vorher erlebt haben dass eben
das Regime und Russland versuchen zu
begrenzen über welche Zugänge über
welchen Zugang muss man sagen unhilfen
ausgebracht werden können da müssen wir
in dieser Notsituation definitiv einen
anderen Weg finden und gehen wir dann
auch mal auf die unterschiedlichen
Herausforderungen in Nordsyrien in dem
Gebiet ein also der Beitrag hat das uns
auch gezeigt es gibt eben
unterschiedliche Gebiete ein kurdisches
Autonomiegebiet die Region die von
islamistischen Rebellen kontrolliert
wird und eben Gebiete die von Damaskus
kontrolliert werden jetzt gerade im
Bezug eben auf den Zugang von Hilfe wie
würden sie ja die Herausforderungen für
diese drei Gebiete unterschiedlich
einordnen
ich denke es sind ganz unterschiedliche
politische Hindernisse die hier im Wege
stehen bei den kurdischen Gebieten also
bei den Autonomiegebieten die sich im
Nordosten Syriens befinden muss man auch
sagen die sind zu ihrem Glück nicht so
sehr wie hitlip oder im latakiat Tattoos
von diesen Erdbeben betroffen gewesen
hier ist aber natürlich eine
Schwierigkeit dass die Türkei keine
Hilfen zu lassen möchte denn da hat es
auch vorher schon immer wieder das
Abschneiden von Wasser Zuflüssen etc
gegeben also hier wird auch humanitäre
Versorgung selbst wenn es jetzt nicht
auf den krisenmodus nach dem Erdbeben
bezogen ist politisiert nun ist es in
eclip so das eclip eingeschlossen ist
auf der einen Seite hat es die Gebiete
des Regimes das ihm nicht freundlich
gesonnen ist auf der anderen Seite die
Türkei die kontrolliert was nach eclip
kommt hier haben wir einen gewissen
Zugang aber bei dem steht auch entgegen
dass die Vereinten Nationen die eben der
größte Geber und die größte Organisation
sind über die Hilfe geliefert werden
kann durch den Sicherheitsrat
eingeschränkt sind und eben hier nur ein
Grenzübergang noch zur Verfügung haben
und die Hilfen die aus dem regimegebiet
hier hinkommen sollen Assad hat ja
gesagt alle Nothilfe soll jetzt über
Damaskus gehen das hieße es müsste
Konfliktlinien überschreitend von der
mussten Damaskus aus nach etlip gebracht
werden das wird nicht funktionieren in
den regimegebieten ist es ein wenig
leichter ich denke der un-zugang ist ja
einfach schon mal besser aber eine der
ganz wichtigen im Beitrag auch benannten
Dinge nämlich personelle Hilfe
Bergungsgerät das hat bislang auch dort
nicht funktioniert das liegt unter
anderem an dem Misstrauen denn das
Regime sowohl westlichen Staaten als
auch tatsächlich der UN gegenüber hegt
sie nehmen gerne das Geld aber weniger
gerne lassen sie sich von anderen
ExpertInnen in die Karten schauen und
das ist hier auch eine Schwierigkeit
und welche Probleme wenn wir uns auch
noch mal darauf genauer konzentrieren
macht vielleicht auch dieser Konflikt
zwischen kurdischen Autonomiegebiet und
Türkei wir lesen hier auch in unseren
Kommentaren sowohl bei Facebook als auch
bei YouTube habe ich es gesehen es gab
Berichte auch darüber dass die Türkei
die in Syrien lebenden Kurden trotz
Erdbeben angreifen würde also wie lässt
sich dieser Konflikt jetzt auch noch mal
ganz speziell aktuell einschätzen was
ist da gerade los
auch wir haben gehört über die Bomber
Maus allerdings ist das etwas was ich
nur gestern wahrgenommen habe und wo
auch klar war wen auch immer wieder
befragt haben belegen ließ sich nicht
von wem die bombert Maus ausgegangen
sind es hieß auch es sei das erste
Regime oder ist sein die syrischen
demokratischen Kräfte spricht die in
denen die Kurden die Führung haben es
ist ein sehr kleinteiliges Konflikte
Menge an bestimmten Stellen im Norden
Syriens und deswegen weiß ich nicht ob
wir hier genug Wissen um es zu
kommentieren ich zumindest kann das
nicht
und dann schauen wir auf die Gebiete die
von der syrischen Assad-Regierung
kontrolliert werden wer ist denn da
überhaupt gerade aktuell wem ist es
möglich da zu helfen wer kommt denn da
rein und dran
in den von Assad kontrollierten Gebieten
ist natürlich eine Infrastruktur die
durch das Regime gestaltet ist also die
Ministerien in der Maske haben hier die
Federführung und dort gibt es den
syrischen Roten Halbmond dort gibt es
auch eine eine ein ganzes Netzwerk von
Organisationen die der First Lady
angehören in der Vergangenheit war eines
der wesentlichen Probleme und das wird
sich jetzt auch nicht gegeben haben die
massive Korruption also die
Hilfsbedürftigkeit habe ich ja vorhin
schon herausgestellt das ist ein
Phänomen das in Syrien sich über die
Jahre das Konfliktes konstant in allen
Regionen verschärft hat und hier hat es
besonders in den letzten Jahren sehr
viele Erhebungen sehr viele Berichte
darüber gegeben wie viel Geld eigentlich
an das Regime fließt das dann nicht bei
den Hilfsbedürftigen landet und ist hier
sicherlich ein Problem dass bei der
Nothilfe auch Eintritt und genau da wie
kann man dem entgegnen also wie kann man
sicherstellen das Geld was auch
gespendet wird natürlich für die Region
dass das wirklich da ankommt wo es
gebraucht wird ist es überhaupt möglich
bei einigen Organisationen denke ich ist
sehr klar das ist dort ankommt wohin es
soll aber das ist natürlich mit gewissen
Schwierigkeiten behaftet und da würde
ich sagen insbesondere in regimegebieten
weil es hier klar ist das Regime hat ein
Interesse daran die Wiese zu
kontrollieren und hat deswegen diesen
ganzen
hilfssektor sehr stark unter seinen
Fittichen dort unabhängige Organisation
zu finden da werden sicherlich einige
externen Organisationen Zugänge haben
aber da bin ich mir nicht sicher ob man
Organisation benennen kann in nicht
regiegebieten ist natürlich klar der der
ganze hilfskomplex sind die sogenannten
weißhelme aufgebaut haben der ist aus
dem kriegs- und krisenmodus geboren und
ist auch in dieser Notlage jetzt ganz
wichtig im Wesentlichen sind es die
weißherme die hier Zivilisten in den
Bergen und die hier dafür sorgen dass
die
hilfs-güter auch zum Teil verteilt
werden aber vor allen Dingen auch
koordiniert wird wie überhaupt dann mit
Verletzten umgegangen wird ich denke
hier haben zumindest diese Organisation
aber durchaus auch noch andere Violet
Serie oder molham wir haben hier
durchaus Organisationen den wir
vertrauen können weil ihre Hilfe
natürlich auch die ganze Zeit sehr eng
gemondet wird gerade in etlip haben
viele Geber ja auch die Sorge deswegen
der islamistischen Rebellen hier die
Hilfe in die falschen Hände geraten
könnte deswegen denke ich wir haben hier
eine ganze Reihe von Organisationen die
aus Gaziantep die ganze Zeit schon sehr
gut sich engagiert haben und gibt es
insgesamt auch an Sie die Frage zum
Schluss insgesamt also genug auch Hilfe
von westlicher Seite überhaupt also wir
haben darüber gesprochen es ist schwer
dass sie reinkommt aber ist auch genug
da
das Ausmaß ist dieser Katastrophe ist so
groß und es trifft wirklich die
verletzlichsten die schon über die Jahre
so viel verloren haben wenn wir uns vor
Augen halten von den vier Millionen
Menschen die in itlipp Leben ist
mindestens die Hälfte schon vertrieben
worden die haben schon einmal oder sogar
mehrfach alles verloren deswegen denke
ich das Ausmaß des Bedarfs übersteigt
hier alles was bislang
zugesagt wurde ich denke auch dass wir
über die nächsten Jahre hier einfach
noch sehr viel mehr brauchen werden und
das
übersteigt auch finanzielle Bedürfnisse
also hier leben viele Menschen die auch
überhaupt keine Perspektive haben die
jetzt noch ihre Unterkünfte verloren
haben deswegen wäre auch der Moment
deutlich darüber nachzudenken kann man
weitere flüchtlingskontingente aufnehmen
kann man weitere Möglichkeiten schaffen
für verwundete aus Syrien rauszukommen
denn auch das ist bislang nicht erfolgt
die Grenze ist dafür geschlossen im
Gegenzug jedoch werden als der Türkei
tote nach Syrien zurück überstellt es
sind wirklich zynischer und höchst
dramatische verhält bei denen wir hier
ganz viele Ansatzpunkte haben die sich
noch ändern müssten
jetzt muss ich noch mal nachfragen zum
Schluss weil sie gerade ja was gesagt
haben sie sagen also tote Leichen die
werden die kommen über die Grenze aber
Menschen kommen nicht raus verstehe ich
sie da richtig könnten sie das für uns
noch mal einordnen ja das ist ein sehr
trauriger Umstand und sehr zynisch es
ist natürlich so dass auf der türkischen
Seite die Krankenhäuser auch völlig
überlastet sind und deswegen sind diese
geschlossen deswegen hat man keine zu
sagen getroffen dass Verwundete und
schwerst verletzte aus Sirene
heraustransportiert werden können in
Syrien selbst haben wir über die letzten
Jahre immer wieder das Problem auch
benannt hier werden hier sind
systematisch Krankenhäuser vom syrischen
Regime und von Russland bombardiert
worden deswegen ist die Hilfe in
Krankenhäusern in eclip sehr
eingeschränkt das sind wirklich
fürchterliche Verhältnisse unter denen
hier gehandelt und operiert werden muss
deswegen wäre es so wichtig auch hier
verwundet zu evakuieren das ist aber
bislang nicht erfolgt und stattdessen
eben wurden nur tote nach Syrien
überstellt Syrer Dinge die eben in der
Türkei an folgendes Erdbebens gestorben
sind
Einschätzung von Bento Scheller von der
heinrich-böll Stiftung vielen Dank dass
Sie bei uns zu Gast waren
schönen Abend noch ebenso
das waren Einschätzungen heute zu Tag 3
nach dem Erdbeben Tag drei nach dieser
Krise es ist eine schwierige schwierige
Situation die letzten Stunden eben der
Rettung viele Menschen die viel Hilfe
brauchen wer also spenden möchte für die
Menschen in dem Erdbebengebiet in der
Türkei und in Syrien wer das tun möchte
der kann das tun beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die IBAN ist
de65100 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben Türkei
Syrien wir haben gelernt und gehört in
dieser Sendung Hilfe die bringt benötigt
benötigt wird Hilfe dies teilweise noch
viel zu wenig gibt dann viel zu wenigen
Orten wir behalten das Thema für euch im
Blick ihr seid auch jederzeit bei uns
natürlich live informiert online bei ZDF
heute und jetzt erstmal danke für eure
Aufmerksamkeit heute und bis zum
nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]